las restricciones fronterizas entre
francia y alemania- que entran en vigor
este martes afectan a la región francesa
de mosela ya los dos estados federados
alemanes con los cuales limita y afecta
en particular según informaron medios
alemanes a unos 16.000 trabajadores
fronterizos que partido este martes
deberán presentar un test negativo el
coronavirus si desean cruzar la frontera
la medida también limita el transporte
aéreo en buses o en trenes entre las
regiones afectadas aunque también se
anunciaron excepciones por ejemplo para
ciudadanos o residentes en alemania y
también se esperan que el transporte de
mercancías no se vea afectado la
frontera con francia no es la única en
la que actualmente hay controles de
hecho alemania ya impuso controles
fronterizos en su frontera con austria
en particular por la situación en nada
la región austriaca de tirol y también
en su frontera con república checa esas
restricciones fronterizas responden a la
preocupación que hay aquí en alemania
por las variantes de coronavirus algunas
de las cuales son
consideradas más contagiosas también es
la razón por la cual hay restricciones a
los viajes internacionales con otros
países que han estado particularmente
afectados por esas variantes como brasil
sudáfrica reino unido o irlanda